our home editor is with us this morning
hi Jason your thoughts good morning
well my thoughts are that
um in the press conference that Lewis
Casey gave yesterday she described this
as a gift you know she said this is
something that I'm passing on to uh the
senior people within the meta police to
really understand the workings of where
where the police force is failing and
she really identified
in quite fine detail a lot of problems
and I think the chief amongst them was
the failure for of women and
investigating women and this one thing
she described as symbolic in that was
how fridge fridges that were used to
store evidence were broken or they
couldn't shut the fridge doors or they
were burgeoning with rape kits that
weren't properly sorted and sometimes
their evidence got contaminated and that
meant that rape cases didn't go forward
didn't proceed because of that simple
failure and I think anyone listening to
this will find that increa incredibly
infuriating
um but she's right to call it symbolic
because the fridge door essentially is
broken on the whole police force and the
whole police force is contaminated until
it can get rid of racism and and sexism
and homophobia and she had she was very
self-conscious I thought of the fact
that there had been so many other
reports and would this report will
really lead to change she talked about
defensiveness and police making Hollow
promises or fake change not seeing
things through properly and I suppose
very much from your interview this
morning with Mark Rowley that fear will
emerge again because he's not accepting
the fact that this is an Institutional
problem and I know that she will be
disappointed in that she did Express
confidence in Mark Rowley in in that
press meeting but I think she will be
disappointed that at the first hurdle if
you are there's a stumble there's a
stumble by the police not accepting that
it's institutionally racist sexist and
homophobic when that is exactly what
Louise Casey is saying there to share
with you the home secretary's just
tweeted she says it's clear that there
have been serious failures of culture
and leadership in the metropolitan
police which is why the commissioner Sir
Mark Rowley has been taking action to
restore confidence in policing in London
I will continue to hold the commissioner
to account to deliver a wholesale change
in the 4 cultures there's much to do and
the task of rooting out unfit offices
means that further unacceptable cases
will come to light so basically
accepting that there's more bad apples
to be highlighted
yeah and I spoke to Sir Bradman
yesterday about this and and she said
pretty much this a similar thing
um and I think that you know it is down
to partly government and Leadership and
that was very much identified by Louise
Casey to to Really push through these
changes and one of the things that
Louise Casey said could change today
would be to Simply say that if a police
officer has got a history of domestic
violence or exposing themselves that's
it they should be out you've we've heard
and even just on the sofa there you we
we heard London's mayor saying that they
should be fully investigated again
that's not what Louise Casey is saying
not just investigate them again and look
at these cases again if they have that
Mark on their record they're not fit to
be a police officer because how can that
person as Louis Casey said to me how can
that person then go to a case of
domestic violence if that's something
that they're doing in their own home
life